let's bring it all together you know we
talked about the social issues in that
in the united states um which led to you
know a lot of questions about black
lives matter and wokeness and trans
issues and then we have what's going on
with the geopolitical conflicts we have
this story from timcast.com
men prevented from getting vasectomies
under china's new family planning
policies china is trying to stave off a
population crisis caused by its
declining fertility rates
with over 1.4 billion people the decline
could create a crisis as the population
ages and is not replaced the densely
populated nation could run out of
workers which would cause severe
economic consequences this is
fascinating
in the united states we have no such
effort we have the opposite they're
telling people to not have kids they're
saying if you want to save the
environment have no kids i've been
saying for a while it really feels like
there is a an effort from global elites
to convince americans to burn down their
own country
china will keep growing and perhaps it's
because they are scared of thucydides
trap that when a rising economic power
reaches the level of us of the sitting
economic power war becomes extremely
likely it feels like there are powerful
interests that are just saying look
either the world implodes from a great
conflict between two superpowers or we
let america down slowly and let him
spiral out of control then
and then china takes over do you really
want the model where that runs three
genocides at the same time and has a and
has a murder for budding murder for
organs industry that's uh you know state
sanctioned yeah you want that model
across the world no but i'll tell you
this the the uh political establishment
here in the us does the idea that they
with absolute authority never have to
worry about an election again that they
can just go in with a with an iron fist
and a rubber stamp and wipe your house
off the map to build a highway they
would love it
that's a very disturbing thought
and that's and that's what they do in
china
that's that's exactly what they do in
china that's exactly what they can do
and they do do
they do do
and they will uh and if we if we don't
stand up and we don't speak out and we
don't support what we believe in uh the
democrats and the neocons the yield libs
and the neocons will do do here as well
and all over our constitution
and it is funny but it's true though i
mean
we
we've talked to several people who have
you know um they cover chinese issues
you know related to like foreign policy
and they talk about what what the
chinese communist party does and we're
told that there was a period where you
know democratic establishment
politicians saw what they do in china
how they one day can walk up to a group
of houses and say destroy it all and
throw those people in the gutter in the
gutter and then we're going to build a
government facility here and they can do
it like that or or the state exactly
what they did to build the stadiums for
the 2008 olympics they took the water
away right
did they take the water from like
farmers and peasants they at the every
every level of you know basically
disenfranchisement taking people's homes
away without any due process to use that
term used earlier
um it just they and frankly raised a lot
of history actually you know these
hutong areas and so forth this is also
why uh justin trudeau says that he uh
looked up to china's basic dictatorship
describing their kind of economic power
and centralization which allows them to
control the markets whichever way they
want uh and it doesn't surprise me that
someone like justin trudeau made those
statements i want to comment so this
about this control right why why do they
have this situation with the you know
sort of preventing vasectomies now right
china one of china's most massive
problems is this demographic cap that
they created through these crazy control
policies the one child policy right
so they i mean this is a massive problem
for them they're not going to solve it
by force preventing people from getting
vasectomies they don't actually have no
one this is one thing that i've never
heard any remotely credible solution to
this
um other than perhaps i mean immigration
might be the solution but no one wants
to go live in a dictatorship that that
does what it does well china doesn't
allow immigration their their their
borders are almost predominantly closed
they're very nationalistic and they
treat outsiders uh according to many
accounts uh very wrong to say one at
least one of the biggest detriments to
the woke left is that if they are
unsuccessful in their attempts to get
their ideology in schools they will
eventually cease to exist and the math
is actually really simple i've actually
covered this it's very interesting there
is a pew research poll showing that
generation z is slightly more
conservative than millennials but still
very progressive in the same way
millennials are just leaning a little
bit and a lot of people assumed this
meant that generation z was like waking
up they were realizing but it's not true
what we're actually seeing is
the ramification of
of replacement levels from the early
2000s so if you go back to the early
2000s you'd see many studies show
liberals were having something like 1.5
kids on average and conservatives were
having 2.01 which meant conservatives
are replacing themselves and liberals
weren't fast forward 20 years what do
you get you get 20 year olds voting
and they lean a little bit more right
not because
they believe what conservatives believe
but just because there are more
conservative gen z than there are
liberal ones that will persist but
as many people have pointed out
progressives and leftists don't have
kids they have yours
so if they cannot get their ideology in
schools then we're looking at 20 40
years two more cycles in the two more
generations and the united states
becomes overwhelmingly conservative so
this is why they hate first of all the
idea of school choice but the other
thing i was going to ask you yan because
you're somewhat the authority is what on
earth was china thinking how can you not
look at for example a one child policy
and a country where they kill millions
upon millions of little girls before
birth after birth doesn't matter to them
and think this will be fine in the long
term i don't understand they're thinking
well and you know that's just just to
highlight that point there's this crazy
situation in china where there's just
all these males that can't find
someone to
yeah like it you know
go ahead you think that's what they were
going for because that was something i
noticed a long time ago if i was like if
you have a bunch of disenfranchised
lonely single young men what are they
going to want to do oh right go to war
exactly and i was like is this this is
the strategy i think i think they simply
imagine and this is the problem with
these you know command top control
social
sort of utopian
vision control systems right you don't
there's there's all sorts of collateral
damage that you can create i don't think
they thought it through i'll be
perfectly honest i really don't think
they thought through it all they just
thought hey we want to limit the
population size this is great let's do
it i i i disagree a little bit i think
uh ladies and something with war
because why would they tell these men
who can't find lovers not to get
vasectomies right because they don't
know who's going to survive and if
random guys are going out saying well i
can't find a mate i'm going to get you
know my balls chopped off anyway then
what happens when many people go to war
and the ones who remain are unable to
have children so they're basically
saying no no everybody remained fertile
and then when 30 of you die in the
conflict of the united states through
cities trap then all right we'll we'll
figure out who then can have kids well
there's a big population crisis in china
the the chinese government has also been
caught building databases of women and
their fertility ranking wow um and and
we have to understand that this one
child policy was cheered on by a lot of
internationalists by a lot of globalists
including the founder of cnn ted turner
that openly said that this was a great
plan this is awesome this is what the
world should be implementing the people
who opened up china to the world henry
kissinger david rockefeller the ones
that took american jobs and sent them
overseas for cheap slave labor those are
the individuals that also cheered on
those policies because they were also
big proponents of population control and
eugenics
and we see similar empathetics by the
world economic forum we see similar
epithets said by individuals like you
know i have to say it bill gates and
other individuals uh but but those
policies i wouldn't be surprised were
made as a part of a deal according to my
own kind of perspective and opinion
saying hey we're going to give you all
these jobs we're going to give you all
these corporations coming to you but you
need to implement the policies that we
want you to implement top down control
spying on citizens social credit score
and a system where of course we regulate
and control the population and almost
every aspect to me china is the
globalist experiment and now china's
saying hey we need more people we're
dealing with a population uh uh
crisis here and we need to take action
and they are taking very
strong actions for that when when it
comes to the fertility question you know
it just just occurred to me there is
this you know you're probably aware of
this this sort of dramatic drop in male
fertility certainly in the u.s they've
done you know extensive studies but it's
abroad they think
it's unclear what the mechanism is they
think it's some basically chemicals in
the system now china is the most
polluted country right they basically
have very very limited pollution
controls there's all sorts of you know
basically human human
devastation as a result of that i wonder
if there isn't also a fertility crisis
even worse than there is here in the us
and in in the free world so to speak you
ever see the buzzfeed video from the try
guys
yeah so these were four guys it was
buzzfeed right yeah i think so and these
four guys young millennial men decided
to get their testosterone levels checked
and i don't think they did research into
this because when they went and did and
then published the results their
testosterone was comparable to to to
that of like 80 year old men
it was bad it was bad so i mean
these guys but then all just all of them
had this
yeah and all their testosterone was way
below average and they're and they're
what they're in their 20s or something
yeah i think so that's that's at their
prime and these guys the test run was
comparable to like elderly men but this
wasn't something of the fact that they
were hanging out with each other or
something like that i don't know i'm
just saying i think i think we're seeing
something with uh with the
infantilization of the millennial
generation and uh potentially gen z
you know i've long thought about this
how um you know i read a lot about how
dogs became domesticated and how they
were wolves
and dogs are effectively permanent
puppies they retain the behaviors of
puppies the love the desire but they
don't ever develop the alpha independent
and controlling and dominant nature of
the wolf
this was bred out of them by humans who
didn't want that the humans wanted to be
in charge so
long story short
when wolves started scavenging the
refuse of human camps the wolves that
were more tolerant and had the right
behaviors were tolerated by the humans
and the humans were more tolerant of the
wolves had a hunting partner with with
wolves and then proto dogs but
eventually this artificial selection
breeds out or i guess technically
natural selection at this point because
it wasn't planned
bred out the aggressive wolf behaviors
and then what ends up happening is proto
dogs were like permanent wolf puppies
and so i see something similar in where
we're going now with humans we are
becoming childlike humans in their in
their uh mid-20s have never had a job
before they're uh they're they're
they're 35 year old men hosting podcasts
who have no kids and aren't married
but it's true
you know my dad i think he was 27 he had
two kids
and uh i think the average age of a
woman have a child even today is still
24 but we're seeing that pushing back i
think now among like you know
millennials it's getting way lower that
that that average still comes from the
older generation that when they're asked
when was the how old were you when you
had your first kid they're like 24 so
that factors in it's probably 21. but
it's so you know it's a lot of this is
really social conditioning i mean it
isn't the thing that you should do to
have lots of kids i mean it is in
hasidic communities for example like my
brother-in-law you know he has he has
five kids his his uh daughter married
into a family of 13 this is just what
you do in orthodox jewish communities
but you don't do it in
you know mainstream american society in
fact it's kind of odd to have a lot of
kids right this is why the future is
conservative and religious
because um there's there's two big
factors here and this and this is again
if the leftists fail in schools their
ideology will will age out with them
conservatives are substantially less
likely to advocate or have abortions and
they're also substantially more likely
to have children in the first place
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time